[Musique]
ici on est sur un lieu de dans une zone
de culte puisque on a encore les
vestiges d'un immense temple un immense
temple en pierre donc un temps de
construit à la romaine ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que dessous il ya deux
niveaux de temples gaulois exactement au
même endroit pendant très longtemps on
disait temple de janus
bon maintenant on prend des précautions
ont dû temple dit de janus ce temple est
pas du tout des janus tout simplement ça
remonte au 16e siècle on parlait de la
tour de la jeune toi brusquement c'est
pas pourquoi ce temple ce tour de la
jeune toi c'est devenu un beau jour
temple de janus sûrement que ça faisait
plus
[Musique]
là ce théâtre là il ya de beaux restes
mais il faut savoir qu'il reste peu de
choses de ce théâtre qui était immense
qui faisait 148 mètres de diamètre c'est
le plus grand théâtre du monde romain
d'occident et il y avait tout à côté un
amphithéâtre qui est aussi le plus grand
amphithéâtre de maule connue donc
l'amphitéa ben il faut me croire sur
parole il n'était pas très loin d'ici
les bulles des spectacles étaient
ouverts à tous ils s'étaient gratuit bon
c'est un théâtre classe donc on emprunte
la révolte war ces petits escaliers
ça s'appelle comme ça ces petits
escaliers cd vomitoire ben c'est pas ce
que vous croyez en voilà un
c'est fait pour accéder à sa place la
quitter rapidement voilà comme le mur de
scène a disparu on aura la chance
d'avoir la vue ce qu'on n'avait pas
il ya deux mille ans
[Musique]